So, I've said methods aren't really magic. They're just procedures that have a
first parameter bound to the object. There are some things in Python that are a
little bit more magical than regular methods and we'll call them Magic Methods.
Magic Methods are like regular methods except they get called in special
situations. The most magical of all the Magic Methods is the one called init.
Init takes at least one parameter, that's the self object. Recall that, that
parameter's always bound to the object. It can take more parameters if we want.
Doesn't need to. And what's special about init is it's called to initialize the
object. So, let's add an init method to our restaurant class. And it's usually a
good idea to place it at the top of the class. So, we have two underscores on
both sides. And we're going to take one parameter and we'll take the parameter
the name. So, that means init will have the object we're initializing as self
and a name that's passed in. And all we'll do in the body of init is assign the
name attribute to the value name. If we do this, this will ensure that all
restaurants will have a name attribute. So where's the magic? The magic is that
this method get called when we create a new object of the class. So, let me show
you that in the interpreter. Now before we define init, we could do this. Create
a new Restaurant, passing into parameters. And that would create an instance of
this type. Now, we get an error and the error we get is a TypeError that says
init takes exactly 2 arguments and we only gave it 1. Well, it doesn't look
like we gave it any. It's getting one implicitly, which is the self object. But
it expects two. It expects self as well as the name. So let's give it a name.
Now, we didn't get an error and we'll see that mcdowells has a name attribute
defined as what we passed init. And I should emphasize, the only magic about
init is that it gets called when we initialize a new object. Otherwise, it's
just like a regular method. If we decided that a more appropriate name for our
restaurant would be McD's Mansion of Metameat, well we could call init method,
passing in that new string, perfectly okay. And now, our name has changed to
this value. When I said it's perfectly okay, I mean that it's correct. We don't
get an error from the interpreter, but it's bad form to do this. If we want some
of the code in init to be used other than initializing methods. Well, we should
define that as a separate method. It's confusing to call init.